speaking of bad stuff to put in your  body speaking of getting shot speaking  of  weird Hang-Ups about eating speaking of  rainbows speaking of violence and the  collapse of the media's veneer of  Integrity speaking of regime propaganda  media speaking of strange headlines  speaking of Victory speaking of other  things that I'm obviously right about  speaking of New Yorkers whining speaking  of unnecessary pain and suffering  speaking of not welcoming everybody into  every tent speaking of women and sex  speaking of weird sex stuff speaking of  bad things that everyone seems to agree  upon speaking of the robots speaking of  embracing speaking of love and marriage  in the baby carriage speaking of putting  hands where you shouldn't  Joe  man sometimes my Segways impress even  make